from far away in orbits around the earth
the nuclear Holocaust almost looked
beautiful bright white pin Pricks
dotting the planet's surface glinted up
at the escaping jet for Generations much
of humanity had lived in fear that the
destruction of the world would come from
countries launching nuclear weapons at
each other no one expected it to come
when they started launching them against
themselves the invasion of the weasels
had been as Savage as it was Swift much
of the human population had been wiped
out before any military forces had
mobilized in any significant fashion no
one was sure if the launching of the
nuclear weapons was intentional or
accidental but as soon as one country
fired the others quickly followed suit
but first we want to than the sponsor of
today's video War Thunder are you
looking for the ultimate vehicle combat
experience then allow me to introduce
you to War Thunder in War Thunder you'll
take command of over 2,000 vehicles from
tanks and planes to helicopters and
ships covering A Century of vehicular
Warfare featuring machines from the
1920s right up to modern day each is
intricately designed down to the tiniest
component making battles feel more real
than ever before but here's what really
sets War Thunder apart whether you're
seeking a quick adrenaline fix or a more
strategic combat approach War Thunder
offers both choose from fast-paced
matches or immersive realistic PVP
battles tailored to your style one
customization there's an expansive
system that lets you go wild with
countless camouflages or decorate them
with historical markings and unique 3D
details like bushes or equipment one
feature I absolutely love is The Game's
Dynamic vehicle damage system instead of
simple hit points vehicles take
realistic damage ever wondered what's
happening inside during a fight the
damage x-ray feature shows the real-time
impact on components and crew dive into
War Thunder now on PC PlayStation 5 or
Xbox x and S or the previous console
generation be sure to click the link in
the description since new players are
those who've been away for over 6 months
can claim your large bonus pack with
multiple premium Vehicles an exclusive
3D decorator and more but hurry it's
only available for a limited time
Earth's rich and Powerful the 1% of the
1% stared in silence as their home was
ripped apart the High Altitude jet
carrying them steadily descended back
down to earth in the direction of the
Antarctic 500 people in total chosen as
the successors of the human race
shuffled off the Jet and threw the
Frozen Outpost an alarm blared wrenching
all of them out of their shell shocked
silence a second later the station shook
violently they had been found there was
no time left they needed to leave right
now the swarm of people stampeded
through the Outpost throwing one another
out of the way in a desperate attempt to
save their own lives to save the lives
of the human race in front of them the
portal stood open the Green Pastures
beautiful trees it all felt so offensive
as as the Earth behind them was engulfed
in war all those countless beautiful
spaces were torn apart and left to waste
but they couldn't think about it now
they had to make it through the handful
of the survivors of the human race ran
through the open portal just as an
explosion ripped apart the remaining
Outpost SCP 001 yellow refers to a base
of operation used for a foundation
continuance protocol specifically
project yellow in the event of a world
destroying catastrophe where Humanity
appears irrevocably doomed there is one
Bastion of Hope referred to as the
Garden of Eden by some of the crew
yellow contains a large circular Central
space complete with lush green grass and
an orchard measuring 500x 500 M this
open space constitutes the main living
area of project yellow surrounding the
space are tall sheer Cliffs to Vertical
to be climbed uned built into these
Cliffs are 500 sleeper Chambers in which
those evacuated from planet Earth will
be suspended in cryosleep until a time
when Earth is fit to be repopulated or a
new home has been discovered how can the
foundation guarantee that this Safe
Haven avoids the calamities that could
befall planet Earth by housing project
yellow in a separate Dimension a pocket
Dimension to be specific following the
successes of project bifrost in which
SCP 2591 D omega's ability to access
fictional pocket Dimensions was utilized
the foundation was able to establish a
relatively stable and reliable dimension
for yellow to occupy the only way to
access the base of operations was via a
dimensional Rift or portal housed deep
in the Antarctic now of course if
yellow's population consisted of 500
people in cryosleep cut off from planet
Earth there would be no one capable of
conducting maintenance or assessing the
possibility of returning to planet Earth
therefore carved into the cliffs
alongside the sleeper cells were living
quarters for the crew of 60 specialists
it was this Workforce who sat down
together on the night of the apocalypse
and raised a toast in a more Bittersweet
celebration all 500 of the evacuees had
managed to make it safely through the
portal before its collapse each of them
had been welcomed to project yellow and
shown to their individual sleeper pods
before being entered into cryosleep for
the foreseeable future but as each of
the crew members raised their glasses
into the air Dr Katrina Keys couldn't
help but feel uneasy about the
proceedings working in this job you'd
have to have a dark sense of humor and
an ability to move past things that
could destroy the mental well-being of
your average person even then she
struggled to come to terms with the near
destruction of the human race for her
and the rest of the crew life would look
nothing like it did before they arrived
here it was vital for the Integrity of
the project that the crew remained
consistent and effective in their work
indefinitely as a result yellow had been
set up with perpetuity in mind every 55
years she and all her crew mates would
pass pass on their knowledge memories
and entire sense of being into a genetic
clone they would then die allowing their
clone to take over the responsibility of
those tasks in another 55 years this
would repeat again and again and again
all this time it is the crew's
responsibility to monitor the status of
Earth through the use of 100 drones once
the Earth is deemed safe all 500
sleepers may be awoken and briefed on
the current situation if all 500
unanimously vote that return rning to
Earth is safe they will do so otherwise
they will return to cryosleep and the
process will continue it was little
wonder that Dr Keys was unable to raise
a glass with her colleagues at the
prospect of being stuck here cloned
indefinitely for Generations she sat in
silence as they raised their glasses and
then emptied them a couple of them
coughed and sputtered their drinks must
have gone down the wrong way but then
more coughs filled the room along with
choking sounds much to Dr Keys's hor hor
within less than a minute she found
herself alone surrounded by the 59
corpses of her crew mates in order for
project yellow to be viable indefinitely
it was Paramount that they find a
solution for natural wear and tear
through generation after generation of
usage essential items such as tools
computer systems and even articles of
clothing would eventually wear away and
fall into disrepair as such project
yellow was set up as a selective entropy
Zone in which inorganic matter would not
degrade over time achieving such a Zone
was naturally an incredibly difficult
undertaking project bifrost underwent
countless iterations as the team strive
to create a stable and balanced
fictional pocket Dimension capable of
sustaining human life long term over the
next few days after the death of her
crewm mates Dr Katrina Keys read through
as much as she could about project
bifrost in the notes she found records
of Dimensions where lava rained from the
sky and the grass was radioactive yellow
had been the first First Dimension
without any glaringly obvious hazards
for human life but naturally their work
had quirks one key Quirk was that the
chemical composition of Cyanide and
their drinks had been switched with one
another the only crew member not to
raise a toast had been the only crew
member not to drink a glass full of
poison months went by leaving Dr Keys
alone to assess her situation the drones
strategically positioned all around
Earth to monitor its safety levels had
been systematically destroyed by the
weasels only one feed remained a
security camera on the other side of the
portal and the Antarctic Outpost there
was virtually no Intel to go off of no
way of knowing what the status of planet
Earth was aside from the fact that this
one burnt out shell of a room still
existed some days Keys would stare at
the screen for hours forgetting to go to
bed on others she would walk through the
orchard trying her best to pretend that
nothing outside of this 500x 500 m space
existed in a away it didn't the orchard
of yellow did not consist of your usual
apple trees instead suspended from
branches were essential supplies that
the crew would need while Manning and
maintaining this base of operations some
trees grew antibiotic drugs others long
strands of linen capable of being
fashioned into clothing Dr Keys's
favorite tree was the one that grew
rolls of toilet paper and tubes of
toothpaste it almost reminded her of a
Halloween prank Dr Keys's mental state
steadily deteriorated as year after year
she walked through the same Orchard
alone never before in history had one
human being had so much control over the
fate of the human race at any moment Dr
Keys could have inputed a few simple
commands into the computers and killed
off all 500 of the remaining human
beings in existence the decision not to
to hold on to hope that one day Humanity
will be able to start again was the only
thing that kept her going day after
Lonely Day only that and the other thing
the prospect of having to prepare for
her clone to take over while
constructing the cloning pods the crew
had made a number of small errors the
most glaring of which was that the fact
that while all of the genetic material
would be transferred from one person to
their clone Offspring The mine would not
in other words the Clone that would
replace her in this facility in 55 years
time would be starting out from scratch
as a regular newborn baby no memories no
Advanced cognition so Dr keys about
preparing for the next ofkin she herself
would die in the cloning process meaning
that she would need to come up with a
way of raising a child to be capable of
running the whole facility from Beyond
the Grave item one on her to-do list
create a God that her offspring would
forever be in service to with a sardonic
smile Dr Keys came up with an
appropriately amusing name Tracy the
sparkling 70 years later yellow was
still operated by just a single crewmate
only now this crew mate was a 15year old
old girl nicknaming herself kk2 she went
about all of her daily tasks with
infectious excitement the idea that she
alone was responsible for the fate of
the human race could not make her
happier and she was determined not to
screw it up both for her sake and to not
anger her God Tracy the sparkling whom
she worshiped every evening before bed
whenever a problem would come up she
would go and visit kk1 where she knew
she would be met with Sound Advice
pushing open the door to the crew Court
ERS KK 2 would find the corpse lying on
the floor in its usual place as a number
of pre-recorded messages would bark at
her lesson NE 957 why taking a bath is
important even if no one but you will
ever know how you smell all she had to
do was not anger the disciplinary drones
with their harsh tasers and do her duty
until it was time for kk3 to take over
at that point she'd be welcomed into the
Afterlife with all the other kks a
wonderful and magical place known simply
as Burger King that was until kk2 got
far enough through the audio recordings
of her predecessor to discover that
Tracy the sparkling was entirely made up
and her life meant nothing it was just a
stepping stone for another clone for
another clone for another clone until
eventually the Earth would be okay by KK
52 the remaining cameraon Earth the one
housed in the Antarctic Outpost went
offline while inorganic material within
yellow compound would not undergo aging
the same could not be said of the
circuitry left on Earth generation after
generation of KK lived and died each one
growing more spiteful towards the one
that came before them each one did their
best to undermine the one that would
come after them the lore around Tracy
the sparkling expanded further and
further with each generation there would
be waves of Highly religious kks
followed by waves of devot atheistic
ones as each sought to rebel against
their pseudo parents KK 89 was the first
to expand the the religious movement to
include the teaspoons very methodically
she went through each teaspoon in the
canteen and named it after a different
animal from Earth before long subsequent
kks established a shrine to the
teaspoons the living space of project
yellow steadily descended into madness
with writings all over the walls bizarre
decorations and rituals long forgotten
until a new KK came along and invented
something to take their place KK 216
lived her entire life in silence never
once recording an audio log or even
talking to herself she lived and died
walking through the Garden in silence
wrapped up in Linens KK 310 did the
opposite she fancied herself a music
composer and scalled the lyrics to
haunting Symphonies about nuclear
apocalypse Eternal isolation and the
prospect of the Angel of Death coming to
rescue her across all of the walls no
matter how hard any of the kks tried
however none of them were able to hack
into the cloning machine generation
after generation of Dr Keys lived and
died desperate to know what a friend was
to have someone else to talk to but
despite all their best efforts they were
unable to tamper with the cloning
machine to get it to spit out another
person for several hundred years the kks
gave up entirely that was until KK 507
came along day after day she sat at the
cloning machine desperately typing away
at it trying her best to figure out how
the computer coding worked the downside
of living in a pocket Universe was that
none of the computer circuitry behave
the way it would on Earth she was
certain that she'd made progress any
generation now they were going to have a
breakthrough and be able to make a
friend when all of a sudden a totally
alien noise filled the containment space
the sound that hadn't been heard for
Millennia alert door controls overridden
opening KK 507 turned around in horror
to see that the portal the entrance to
their world from Earth had been opened
the figure of a man no not a man a robot
painted to almost look like a crash test
dummy stepped out into the orchard hello
the goddess has informed us that this is
the last Bastion of the true human race
is that correct KK 507 opened her mouth
and screamed thanks again to the sponsor
of today's video War Thunder don't
forget to click the link in the
description where new players can get a
large bonus pack with multiple premium
vehicles and exclusive 3D decorator and
more but hurry it's only available for a
limited time now go check out SCP 001
you are the anomaly and SCP 001 the
broken God or borrow cycle for more